foreign
welcome to another installment of Harry
Potter Theory today we're going to be
discussing the dursley's Harry Potter's
awful adoptive family more specifically
we're going to be breaking down three
thought-provoking Harry Potter fan
theories that pertain to the members of
this dysfunctional family let's get into
it one Harry's Hallows what if I told
you there was a connection between the
dursleys as seemingly mundane if you
count out Harry's side of things family
living in little whinging Surrey and the
fabled Magical Tale of the Deathly
Hallows which centers around three
artifacts crafted by death himself and
the three wizard brothers who received
them as gifts because as it turns out if
we really dissect Harry Potter lore and
dive in deep some may call it stretching
there is a connection here the three
Deathly Hallows from Legend were the
resurrection Stone a stone with the
power to resurrect one's loved ones
albeit not properly the invisibility
cloak a cloak that can turn the wearer
invisible and the Elder Wand the most
powerful wand in all of existence
but while these artifacts sound
impressive on their own you'd be
hard-pressed to find a wizard more
powerful than the one who possessed all
three at once a true master of death
glancing back at the Harry Potter story
it's certainly not news that the
dursley's mistreated Harry however as it
turns out one particularly cruel Act is
noteworthy as it establishes a
connection between the Hallows and
Harry's Christmas gifts over the course
of the novels Harry receives three
Christmas presents from the Desi family
a 50 pence piece a toothpick and a
single tissue Harry also got a pair of
socks but it's important to note these
socks were a birthday present what this
Theory suggests is that the 50 pence
piece is a representation of the
Resurrection Stone the toothpick is a
representation of the Elder Wand and the
single tissue is a representation of the
invisibility cloak what do you think was
this Easter egg planned by Rolling or
just a huge coincidence 2. Harry's Hawk
racks now it's no secret that Harry in
the Desi's never exactly saw my eye and
99 of the time I think that you could
ask you that this toxic relationship is
the fault of the dursleys however one
consideration that I had was that
perhaps the jerseys were influenced by
the long exposure to Harry's hawkracks I
don't think that the horcrux possesses
the ability to completely change them as
people but perhaps it exposes and
exaggerates their inner darker nature
despite openly treating Harry as if he
was their lowly servant punishing him in
Unthinkable ways they seemed to really
love each other and acted quite several
with other members of society this makes
me wonder why did Harry incite such rage
in them we don't know a lot about
Harry's relationship with the Desi's
before the Philosopher's Stone takes
place and we don't know how they treated
him as a baby Harry was left on their
doorstep at such a young age and they
really can't see how instead of
mistreating him they wouldn't have just
tried to raise him as their own this was
a baby who had no preconceptions about
anything at all and they would been able
to meld this baby to someone just like
them if they gave it a chance they could
have at least tried right goo horcruxes
as we know horcruxes can seriously
affect people's behavior and makes them
behave in a much more negative manner
this manner gets progressively worse the
more that you were exposed to the
horcrux we see the same sort of behavior
in Ron when he wears Sutherland's locket
around his neck in the Deathly Hallows
over time he becomes moodier and moodier
with each passing minute becoming less
and less like himself so perhaps the
jerseys were affected to a lesser extent
the same way that Ron was affected
however if Harris War krugs makes people
angrier you might argue that it would
have had more of an effect on his close
friends in series my argument for this
is that in the dursley household Harry
would have had the closest proximity to
other people for longer periods of time
at Hogwarts Harry would run around all
over the place and had plenty of
distance between him and others in his
sleeping quarters additionally perhaps
the severity of the negative effect that
horcrux's give off is totally dependent
on the person that's exposed to it maybe
some aren't affected at all While others
are crippled by it the dursleys are just
Muggles so maybe it was just too much
for them maybe the horcrux and Harry
wasn't enough to affect magical folk is
Chad Lee Cannon this Theory aka the
chuddly theory suggests that Harry's
awful cousin Dudley dursley ended up
marrying Ravenclaw graduate Joe Chang
let's break it down this Theory came
about for a couple of reasons but the
main driver behind it is that Cho Chang
ended up marrying a muggle that's Canon
Cho Chang married a muggle furthermore
we also know that Dudley dursley ends up
getting married himself but the name of
his wife is never revealed this is
basically the main basis for the theory
an unnamed wife and an unnamed muggle
but let's bust it open some more we know
Dudley does is a muggle and while it's
only usual for Witch's Wizards to marry
Muggles it definitely still happens
however the main issue with witches
Wizards marrying Muggles is that it will
often cause problems later on we saw
this with Snape's parents which Eileen
Prince and muggled to buy a Snape as
well as with mcgonagall's parents which
Isabel Ross and muggle Robert McGonagall
it happens but usually not without
conflict often when a witch or wizard is
courting a potential muggle spouse they
fail to mention their magical abilities
which causes tension down the line when
their kids start performing magic
themselves the guilt eventually becomes
unbearable and they end up confessing
their magical status to their other half
however the years of lies are not often
entirely understood so in this respect
the relationship between Cho and Dudley
does sort of make sense if Joe were to
have married a regular muggle then she
would have no doubt encountered the
aforementioned difficulties associated
with muggle courtship how however if she
were to end up with Dudley who was a
muggle there is the obvious advantage
that she would never have to hide
anything from him Dudley was privy to
the magical world and there wouldn't
have been much that Cho could have said
to put him off or surprise him okay now
I know what you're thinking Cho and
Dudley Dudley was about as awful as
young boy could be he tormented Harry he
was ruthless to other children and he
was about to spoiled in pompous as you
can get however there was a point in
Dudley's life at which he had a bit of a
Crossroads a dementor attack though the
Dementors weren't able to successfully
suck out Dudley's Soul the attack still
had a profound impact on him as it
forced him to observe the type of person
that he was Dudley really did change and
even later felt remorse for how he had
treated Harry Joe Chang was a bright
witch and even had a brief fling with
Harry Potter himself however the
relationship eventually fell apart due
to her best friend betraying the model's
Army before Harry chosen in love with
Cedric Diggory and after his demise she
certainly had a tough time in school she
really was a lovely young woman and I
can completely see why she ended up
marrying a muggle just wanting to escape
all of The Madness of The Wizarding
World so who better than the new and
improved Dudley dursley who better to
marry than a witch when you're trying to
leave your life of prejudice behind and
who better to marry than a magically
informed muggle when you're trying to
ditch a fully fledged magical existence
I think that the theory is highly
unlikely but possible it's certainly
something to think about and chuddly
really rolls off the tongue what do you
guys think was chudley Canon and that's
it for this video did you guys know
about these theories already are any of
them plausible or are these just perfect
examples of reaching too far as always
if you enjoy the content please like the
video and subscribe to the channel until
next time remember time will not slow
down when something unpleasant lies
ahead